thank you for doing this role because it
means a lot to a lot of people
um do you still send thank you cards to
kenneth branagh for
changing your life yes
i do um
uh i've actually i've actually i think
i've kind of used up all my lives as it
were
of trying to tell him in person um
and um but i have told him in person
several times
but he did he did change my life he has
changed my life
um and continues to um
yeah um but i did actually want to write
exactly that a thank you card for that
exact spread express purpose
um he um and he didn't just do it for me
he did it for chris hemsworth
and he continues to do it for young
actors
all the time it is a a remarkable
capacity
for generosity that he has yeah you
won't remember this but i did a
set visit on the first store and i
remember remember
i do remember i remember you walking
over in costume
and us standing there seeing you and i'm
like oh [ __ ] this this might be really
good
like you know what i mean just seeing
everything we were seeing
um but anyway i don't need to put myself
in this do you see yourself directing in
the future
wow um i switched here completely
yeah um i um
i don't i mean it's something i have
thought about um but i i've also
um i'm also not unaware
and apologize for the double negative
i'm i'm you i'm profoundly aware
of the um
of the responsibility and the
the responsibility of the role and and
of the expertise required
and so i feel as an actor i'm still
learning
every time i go to work i'm still
learning about
about the craft of filmmaking about the
um
the very specific jigsaw puzzle that any
production
becomes and all the elements
that have to work in concert for to give
you
even a chance of of um of everything
you know of everything going to plan
and i'm still learning i think from from
i learn every time as i say from
from from directors of photography from
production designers costume designers
other directors
producers writers who constantly trying
to think about story or think about
the most dynamic and interesting way of
telling that story
and maybe they'll come a time where i
feel i'm
ready to do that but if it doesn't
happen happy to
uh to learn the lines and hit the marks
and um
and pretend to be other people do you
have a favorite theater to perform in
in london um
gosh good question i have a very a soft
spot for the donmar warehouse
in covent garden um where i've performed
twice to er shakespeare productions of
shakespeare plays
othello in 2007 and corey lennis in
2013.
um yeah it's an amazing space
very very the audience is very close to
the action
and i and i as a young student i used to
go down there a lot
and watch other great actors
um performing there and think maybe one
day so
but there but yeah i it's hard to pick
one but if i had to pick one i would
pick that one probably
sure if you could go back in time using
time travel in this question
and do any performance again that you've
done in the theater
that is obviously now closed from your
past uh what would you do
and why it's hard to pick one
i mean i'm immediately thought of three
shakespeare plays um there's something
about
those texts which means
you kind of never feel you've quite got
to the bottom of them
because they're so endlessly
they're so worthy of endless exploration
um
i played cassio in our fellow
um as i say a turtle ego for played
othello
euro mcgregor played iago in an amazing
production full of extraordinary actors
and it was a very happy experience and
i'd love to go back and feel some of
that
some of that warmth again um
[Music]
and then i i played hamlet but
not for very long and i realize with
these plays sometimes
the longer you do it the more the deeper
it goes so maybe i'll go back and
have another go with that but i'm just
look i'm lucky i got to do it once
uh do you think loki will ever get a
love interest
in the upcoming future
um or are we going to encounter that in
this
series you know they say um
in order to have uh you know the first
the first stable relationship you have
to have
is with yourself and
loki is still working on that i think um
but it's a you know i think it's an
interest always an interesting question
i've always been interested in the story
in the in
the comics in
the couple of individuals that loki
allows to get close
in a way that might make him vulnerable
um so yeah
i think i think um
there are questions to be asked in that
in that in that regard
sure did you have a good enough time on
making this series
that the concept of a season two sounds
yes sign me up
i love making this i i really did it was
you know it was because we made it in
the course of the last
year and and on the other side well it
we made it through the pandemic it
became a very
um a very kind i became
everybody on the crew became very
invested in each other because it was
something we were very um committed to
um in some obviously some challenging
circumstances
for all of us and um the people involved
were absolutely extraordinary in their
in their skill level and their
commitment and their generosity of
spirit
and as you know every time
every time we all go to work you go to
work with a group of people and it's
and half the time uh it's
everybody else's inspiration that gives
you
the energy that you need and these
people
kate herron michael wardro and eric
martin kevin wright
owen wilson gugu and batara wummi masaku
sophia de martino and more that i cannot
mention
at this point um yeah autumn derald our
dp
um and her team of in the camera
department
um steve aaron our sound recordist
um who i'd worked with before on i saw
the light
richard graves and christina peterson um
first and second assistant directors
we would not have finished this show
without those two people
um tristana our line producer these
these are the people
that uh don't often get talked about and
they the credit for this show belongs
with them because it was a team game
season two thumbs up i
i know like i know now
because i've played this role a while
and i've died three times or
maybe maybe two or two and a half um
i know now that for me to have any
expectations
about what happens next is a fool's
errand
but i'm along for the ride and um
and you'll have to ask kevin feige and
luis the esposito
about that one i understand thank you so
much for doing this
and uh congrats and have a great day
thank you sir